how's it going everyone this is
International master Daniel wrench this
is chest comms YouTube channel and today
we have another installment into our
chess openings playlist that's right
we're going to keep on trucking with
this chess openings train and try to
make sure we complete the idea of having
every main line every tournament opening
quote-unquote using dr. evil quotation
fingers in our playlist so that you can
use it as an intro especially if you're
someone who really wants to learn a
little bit more about tournament level
chess or organized chess and you're not
just an enthusiast looking for a quick
fix you actually want to try to get
better you can use our openings playlist
to start to improve your knowledge of
the first stage of the game so let's do
this you see from the title we have the
Scandinavian defense on the docket today
the Scandinavian defense is an approach
for black after the move 1.e4 and that
is the move d5 the general idea here is
that black is going to sacrifice some
time and a small amount of space in the
center for the for the opportunity to
eventually have open lines for his
pieces and potentially put white in a
slightly awkward situation I'm going to
talk a little bit about the philosophy
of what happens in the middle games here
even though black loses some time after
the movie takes d5 Queen takes d5 Knight
to c3 basically Black has broken one of
the most oh one of the oldest principles
in the book which is don't bring your
queen out too early right don't don't
use the big girl against the kids and
you're going to run into issues most of
the time if you do that in fact some
amateurs have played this move just
because they like to bring the Queen out
early and retreated this Queen right now
to c6 and not realize that they actually
lose the first lady instantly so that
would be a horrible blunder not really
something we would classify as part of
the Scandinavian offense but just
highlighting why there are some risks
always whenever you bring the Queen out
early but the basic point here is that
even though black is going to lose some
time with the Queen after finding a safe
square white expands in the center and
as we reach a middle game one of the
most important things to understand
about this this pawn structure is that
even though white has gained some time
this development of the knight being in
front of the pawn is not actually ideal
what I mean by that is that ideally in
this type of structure which is actually
a Karol Slav structure where black has
pressure on the D file white would
actually like to have this night behind
this C pawn controlling more squares in
the center and potentially having a much
bigger space advantage it's one of the
reasons why in other openings white will
actually go out of his way to relocate
to try to expand and get his Knights out
behind the pawns to have more space
rather than developing in front of the
pawn so what that does to this position
is that even though black has lost a bit
a little bit of time with the Queen as
we head into one of the mainline
middlegame
type of positions here after Bishop to
f5 Bishop to D to e six black does not
fear this immediate discovery on the
Queen because this Queen can find a safe
square captures pawn captures the move
Bishop to b3 is played to guard this
pawn here and after ninety seven Queen
to e2
black develops white gets castled and
black can also Council long one of the
major things about this position is that
white has not really increased his
control over the center that greatly
black has opportunities to use different
squares and actually at some point to
lash out with a move like c5 to give his
his Knight Bishop more space in the
center something that you may see black
do on the on the black side of like a
classical Carroll Khan in this
particular structure if white had more
time I would have liked to have had the
pawns advanced and and the rooks behind
these two pawns and and really look to
do something with his space advantage
but because he developed in such a way
with the knight on c3 in front of the C
pawn he never really got his ideal
control over the center so black small
loss of time in the center is sort of
made up for definitely we would evaluate
this type of position a slightly better
for white and if white knows the right
plan to execute here which I'm going to
show you white is going to maintain kind
of a small lasting edge here but without
without a really direct approach and
black has if Black has a few moves here
the position is totally solid for black
and again black and at some point try to
challenge the center and have equally
active pieces the right move here for
white does this move Knight h4 which
attacks the bishop on f5 and after
Bishop to g6 modern approaches to
this position saw white trying to be
more aggressive with these pawns even
moves like f4 but after the move f5 this
Bishop seems like a big a big
Frankenstein pawn on g6 but white can't
really do anything taking it would allow
black to fix his pawn structure and
actually have a very solid and
potentially active King side whereas
retreating the knight would actually
allow this bishop to perhaps just trade
himself off and black actually has more
potential in the center with control
over this outpost Square bringing the
knight in there is certainly a
possibility so f4 is no longer
considered the best way for white to
play but rather this move g3 White's
intention is to continue with 90 g2
Knight to f4 followed by driving the H
pawn down to really dislodge blacks
coordination on the Kings side this was
an idea first played by a pawn amariah
of a very strong grandmaster at the
highest level and this type of idea when
executed properly should leave white
with a little bit of an edge in the
middle game but to back up but I want to
show you the other main line for black
in the Scandinavian and that is to
develop the Bishop to g4 instead of f5
and again in these positions the pawn
structure is similar and that black will
try to put pressure on the D file and
take advantage of the D pawn white is
looking for opportunities to sort of
relocate on the Queen side to expand and
get space and after the move h3 Bishop
h5 and the move g4 is played whether
right away or even after the move Knight
to Bishop d2 Knight to d5 Knight takes
f6 again we see the pawn needing to take
here's one example why in this type of
situation especially if you take with
the Queen you regret it after g4 and
Bishop g5 the Queen finds herself
trapped in the middle of the board so in
this case again black takes to the pawn
and like in the other line you should be
aware that black is not really big and a
big of hurt here with the double pawns
because those pawns actually control
many critical squares in the center and
they're not easily targetable by white
because there is no open file there
isn't an easy access for the pieces
coming to the King side so these double
pawns are not your typical double pawns
where they're just evaluated as a
weakness and that's that there actually
is some strength to having these pawns
controlling different points in the
center
so after G takes f6 the move g4 can be
played and once again after Bishop b3 97
Queen e2 Queen c7 you get a very similar
to position to the types we were just
discussing in the Bishop a5 line except
the White has already achieved a small a
small space advantage on the Kings side
but once again I would say this position
is considered to be very solid for black
and black can develop and look for
opportunities to lash out in the center
at some point against the the d4 pawn
which is a typical thing to do in this
in this pawn structure the other thing
that defines this defy break or the
other opportunity black has to play for
is playing Knight f6 instead of playing
Queen takes d5 and this way he's not
wasting time with the Queen and so he he
saves a little bit of saves a little bit
of face in the center there he's not
really losing time with with the Queen
running away from all the pieces but
this this variation which is known as
the pole guy F ski allows white to
actually achieve the sort of
quote/unquote ideal pawn structure a
little bit easier white will typically
want to play d4 and after Knight takes
d5 immediately playing c4 Knight to c3
and remembering in many cases to play
this move h3 to stop the Bishop from
pinning the knight on f3 will head to a
very typical type of middle game here
where White has a space advantage these
two pawns ideally placed in terms of
restricting blacks activity black has a
couple of ways to lash out in the center
but e v is met with d5 and even though
there's a lot more opening theory than
what I'm highlighting here I would say
that white is also maintaining a small
edge in those variations as well so the
main point to understand for black is
that if you're going to play the
Scandinavian and lose time with either
the night by the Pokedex key variation
or the Queen you have to have really
good knowledge of the very of the
variations that follow understand that
at some point even though you've lost
time with the Queen you can relocate the
Queen to assert pressure against the d4
pawn and potentially even change the
pawn structure with c5 or e5 so again to
review those variations I went through a
little bit quickly I would say that
after nice e3 Queen to a5
d for all these moves being natural ways
to gain space Knight f6 Bishop c4 c6 9
f3 again both Bishop f5 and Bishop c4
being black's two main options with
similar positions happening with white
needing to put the bishop on d2 look for
the opportunity to play this discovered
attack on the Queen which in the future
allows white to relocate the pieces and
potentially gain space over here noted
should be for white developing the
Knight to f3 before black has committed
this move c6 which creates the exit
point for the Queen can be semi risky if
black plays Bishop to g4 and tries to
use this square on c6 for the knight
followed by the rook coming to d8 in one
way or another and this way you see all
the black's pieces sort of ganging up on
the d4 pawn and this type of strategy
should not be played unless you really
understand the sharp variations to
follow but it's also totally playable
for both sides but in general when
teaching the principles of this line I
recommend to my students to play Bishop
to c4 postponing the development of this
knight for one more move leaving black
in a position where he where he really
wants to play c6 now on Knight f3 Bishop
c4 is not the end of the world because
the c6 pawn has taken away the square
from the knight preventing black from
getting that sort of ideal development
that puts pressure on the d4 pawn so
again there are going to be mainline
video series over on our main site just
calm by by some different experts of the
Scandinavian but you can use this video
as a little bit of an intro to the the
fundamental ideas behind Black's
approach in the Scandinavian as well as
what white wants to do when transition
to a middle game so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video today and we will see
you around on chess calm